[Musica]
il battito delle ali di una farfalla in
brasile può provocare un tornado in
texas
lo disse edward lawrence climatologo
matematico il primo capire che una
differenza piccolissima gentile in un
sistema complesso come può essere il
clima atmosferico può provocare
conseguenze forti violentissime come può
essere un tornado in texas
ebbene sulle ali della farfalla di
lawrence che ormai un concetto
scientifico acclarato e che si applica a
tutte le scienze vorrei portarvi in un
viaggio nell'attualità della ricerca
scientifica di oggi un viaggio
appassionante eccitante almeno per me
perché questa per me è la avventura più
bella cominciamo con l'astrofisica con
una scoperta di cui sicuramente avete
tutti sentito parlare la scoperta delle
onde gravitazionali premiata dal nobel
per la fisica nel ottobre 2017 l'ultimo
novella attribuito un'onda
gravitazionale
intanto prima di dire che cos'è
ascoltiamola
un cinguettio la chiamano gli americani
un effetto gentile ma in realtà ha
provocato da una perturbazione
l'ambiante ska e provocata da una
collisione di buchi neri di masse 10 20
30 volte più grandi della massa
terrestre che è un miliardo di anni fa
in una regione remo tissima del nostro
cosmo si sono scontrati si sono fusi
questa collisione ha provocato un suono
che è così interpretato dagli strumenti
che sembra gentile ma realtà un suono
potentissimo perché il segnale di una
perturbazione di quello che è il tessuto
più intimo del dell'universo lo spazio
tempo queste onde sono state previste
cento anni fa da albert einstein
esattamente cento anni dopo nel 2015
sono state per la prima volta ascoltate
da strumenti come questo strumenti forti
molto complessi questo è uno dei due
strumenti che si chiamano onlive degli
stati uniti al nord e sud del paese che
contemporaneamente hanno registrato il
passaggio di questa onda gravitazionale
proveniente da un miliardo di anni fa da
una regione molto molto molto lontana
del nostro cosmo e come fanno a
registrare gravitazionale questi
strumenti attraverso degli
interferometri che sono all'interno dei
tunnel che vedete i due bracci in questo
caso lungo lunghi quattro chilometri ed
è stata misurata per la prima volta nel
2015 dai due strumenti
contemporaneamente a quella misura
seguirono altre misure ricordiamo in
particolare quella del lo stesso
interferometro in italia
virgo molto simile al lago all'esterno
qui vediamo l'interno e vediamo lo
strumento appunto questo interferometro
uno strumento complessissimo che è fatto
di fasci laser che vanno e vengono lungo
quei bracci che abbiamo visto fatti a
dell e all'interno i laser vengono
riflessi da degli specchi e quello che
succede quando passa un'onda
gravitazionale che la lunghezza dei
bracci si riduce di una misura
gentilissima dieci alla meno 18 metri
ossia 0,18 zeri e otto metri una misura
infinitamente piccola ma estremamente
precisa misurata dai due laico e da
virgo
e in particolare virgo è stato
protagonista di una misura fondamentale
di queste onde gravitazionali perché era
dovuta alla collisione questa volta non
di due buchi neri ma di due stelle di
neutroni due oggetti molto massicci ma
diversamente dai buchi neri che emanano
anche luce e questo ha voluto dire che
oltre a sentire l'onda gravitazionale
sia laico che virgo tutti i telescopi
del mondo tutti i telescopi montati su
satelliti nello spazio hanno visto la
luce contemporaneamente di queste due
stelle e questa è una scoperta
incredibile la prima volta nella storia
dell'umanità che è un fenomeno cosmico
viene registrato attraverso questi due
segnali il segnale dell'onda
gravitazionale perturbazione dello
spazio tempo ma anche il segnale ottico
visivo misurato da telescopi come quello
che vedete qui che è il più potente
telescopio ottico al mondo nel deserto
di atacama si chiama via alti very large
telescope e anche se si trova in cile è
una conquista europea un telescopio
europeo
un'altra scoperta di cui vorrei parlarvi
di cui sicuramente avete sentito parlare
e che molto si addice alla definizione
di forte e gentile
una differenza piccola gentile un
effetto gigantesco forte e la scoperta
del bosone di higgs nel laboratorio in
cui io lavoro più o meno quotidianamente
il cern di ginevra la mia casa diciamo
la mia casa più stabile rispetto a tutti
i miei viaggi e la scoperta avvenuta
annunciata nel 2012 a dell hc il bosone
di higgs proprio come hanno detto nella
motivazione del premio bella esattamente
l'anno dopo è una particella molto
piccola quindi molto gentile in quanto
il quanto di un campo che però fa tutta
la differenza fa una differenza enorme
pensate senza l'interazione col bosone
di higgs voi io questo puntatore laser
questo palco non esisteremmo saremmo
pura radiazione vagante nel cosmo perché
grazie all'interazione con il campo di
higgs un miliardesimo di secondo dopo il
big bang che le nostre particelle le
particelle che costituiscono il nostro
dna ma anche il materiale di cui è fatto
questo palco o l'ossigeno che respiriamo
e tutti gli elementi della tabella
chimica non sarebbero nulla senza
interagire col campo di
per ora d'azione senza massa è stato
necessario costruire uno strumento
gigantesco come large hadron collider
del cern di ginevra che vediamo in
questa immagine un acceleratore di
particelle potentissimo e grandissimo
circonferenza 27 km vediamo qui il
paragone con la pista dell'aeroporto di
ginevra dietro il lago e il monte bianco
quindi una macchina gigantesca allo
strumento scientifico più grande del
mondo ma anche più complesso e potente
27 chilometri di superconduttori che
tengono insieme due fasci di protoni in
senso opposto circolanti alla velocità
della luce
fasci piccoli come un capello umano 25
metri e tutto questo perché per ricreare
quello che non possiamo più osservare
l'universo alla sua origine l'universo
primordiale l'universo quando aveva un
miliardesimo di secondo dopo la sua
nascita dal big bang non è possibile
osservarlo con i telescopi ottici perché
la luce è nata quando l'universo aveva
300 mila anni di età quindi l'unico modo
oggi che abbiamo per vedere l'universo
la sua nascita e ricrearlo il
laboratorio è a questo serve lhc coni
che con i suoi occhi atlas e cms due dei
quattro grandi rivelatori di particelle
nelle collisioni fra protoni ha visto
nascere il bosone di higgs è di questa è
la sua foto sono state scattate miliardi
e miliardi di foto per anni prima di
annunciare la scoperta perché la
scoperta anche un fattore statistico che
non deve avere assolutamente errore alla
fine e per poi annunciare l'esistenza di
questa particella qui vediamo le sue
tracce depositati all'interno di uno dei
due rivelatori come funziona questa ri
creazione dell'universo in miniatura in
un punto piccolissimo funziona
attraverso una formula che tutti
conoscete è uguale emmeciquadro ma cosa
vuol dire e m energia massa energia
materia e un'equivalenza ok e col c
quadro vuol dire che se si concentra
tanta energia in un punto molto piccolo
molto vuoto si ricrea la stessa
situazione di densità di calore di
temperatura di condizioni fisiche
dell'universo il suo inizio che
spontaneamente si trasforma in
questo succede 40 milioni di volte al
secondo
all'interno del collider lhc all'interno
di questi rivelatori l'energia dallo
scontro di protoni si trasforma in
materia dicevo prima che senza il bosone
di higgs senza il campo di higgs nulla
esisterebbe e tutto quello che esiste
funziona esiste grazie all'interazione
con questo campo in realtà tutto quello
che esiste cioè che noi conosciamo
nell'universo e solo il 5 per cento del
tutto il grande mistero della fisica di
oggi è la materia oscura una materia che
sappiamo c'è ma assolutamente non si
vede perché noi vediamo io vedo te
perché i tuoi fotoni colpiscono la mia
iride e il mio cervello compone la tua
immagine viceversa i telescopi vedono
sempre per scambio di fotoni vedono una
range molto più ampia un campo molto più
ampio di quello che possono vedere i
nostri occhi tutto lo spettro
elettromagnetico ma sempre attraverso
fotoni ebbene i fotoni si sono liberati
dal plasma primordiale a 300.000 anni di
età dell'universo e tutto quello che noi
vediamo funziona per l'interazione
elettromagnetica in realtà esiste una
materia che appunto si chiama oscura che
non emana nulla una materia oscura
fredda ma c'è perché le osservazioni di
astrofisica ci confermano che deve
esserci è stato anche calcolato dove è
quanta ce ne costituisce il 25 per cento
del tutto noi siamo il 5 per cento il
resto è completamente ignoto ma sappiamo
che esiste materia oscura da immagini
come questa queste sono galassie in
rotazione la materia di cui sono fatte
osservabile non giustifica la velocità
del loro movimento e ci sono state tante
osservazioni di questo tipo in cui si
vedono traiettorie di stelle e dei
pianeti deviate deve esserci una massa
che lo fa responsabile di questa
deviazione
ebbene gli esperimenti più sensibili al
mondo per trovare questa materia oscura
non sono lontani da qui si trovano sotto
la caverna del gran sasso sotto la
roccia 1.400 chilometri m
i laboratori nazionali del gran sasso
esistono due esperimenti che sono i più
sensibili al mondo della ricerca di
particelle di materia oscura non ancora
trovate ma studi molto utili
stati fatti hanno stabilito i limiti
della massa che dovrebbe avere il primo
e xenon
lo vediamo in questa immagine
dall'esterno è alto come un palazzo di
circa tre piani e al suo interno
contiene questo strumento incredibile è
un termostato praticamente che contiene
xenon liquido liquido per mantenerlo
liquido deve essere raffreddato almeno
95 gradi e questo materiale ha la
particolarita lo xenon questo gas quando
il liquido di essere estremamente denso
e di avere una possibilità di interagire
con qualche particella di materia oscura
che dovrebbe staccarsi dalla rotazione
della nostra galassia la via lattea e
che poi schermata dalla roccia del gran
sasso arriva pura allo strumento quindi
uno strumento passivo di osservazione
che sta lì in attesa di questa
interazione rarissima un'interazione
piccola gentile ma se viene scoperta
sarà sicuramente un bel perché avremmo
scoperto il 25 per cento di cui è fatto
il tutto assieme a xenon c'è un altro
esperimento al gran sasso che cerca
anch'esso materia scura si chiama dark
side molto simile invece del gas xenon
utilizza l'argon liquido e insieme
cercano inseguono questa materia oscura
hanno fatto tante misure utili ma non
ancora la scoperta e io glielo auguro
vivamente perché se la meriterebbero
davvero sono estremamente precisi e
sensibili e sono fatti dalle menti
giovani di tutti i paesi del mondo più
brillanti che ci siano in questo campo
della fisica al gran sasso c'è anche un
altro strumento borexino che invece di
risultati ne ha già avuti anche tanti
borexino anch'esso possiamo applicare la
logica del forte e gentile cerca una
particella anch'essa molto gentile
anch'essa molto importante il neutrino i
neutrini in particolare che arrivano dal
centro del sole il neutrino una
particella talmente leggera che la sua
massa non è ancora stata misurata ma
talmente abbondante che è talmente può
viaggiare alla velocità della luce dalle
profondità del cosmo che è
importantissimo studiarla questa
particella pensate viene generata
assieme ai fotoni all'interno del centro
del sole che è una stella gigantesca
alla più grande di tutta la nostra
galassia
e mentre i fotoni per arrivare alla
superficie del sole soltanto ci mettono
milioni di anni il neutrino dalla
centro del sole fino a borexino ci mette
8 millisecondi perché viaggia
indisturbato alla velocità della luce
quindi nulla lo può fermare
ed è chiaro che per fermarlo occorrono
grandi masse come borexino con
all'interno un sacco di materiale
liquido gassoso tenuto sotto pressione
con tanti fotomoltiplicatori che sperano
di trovare quell aspetto gentile quella
rara interazione che il neutrino
potrebbe avere col gas e gli atomi del
gas contenuto all'interno di borexino e
quando c'è questa interazione questo gas
consente una scintilla si crea anche un
elettrone insieme al neutrino sono
reazioni nucleari che avvengono
contemporaneamente per cui i
fotomoltiplicatori sperano di vedere
quella scintilla ne hanno già viste
tante perché borexino è stato il primo
esperimento a osservare il flusso di
nutrire isolare in maniera diretta ed è
stato anche il primo esperimento
osservare altri neutrini molto utili
anche alla geofisica sono gli
antineutrini che la nostra terra stessa
genera i geoneutrini cosiddetti bene
vorrei concludere questo viaggio sulle
ali della farfalla di lawrence con il
campo della scienza che più vicino a
lawrence che la scienza del clima la
climatologia con questa immagine di
ghiacciai che abbiamo filmato assieme al
mio compagno alla settimana scorsa in
artico alle svalbard sono tornato a
martedì da questo viaggio sui ghiacciai
delle svalbard una terra che si trova al
di sopra del circolo polare artico molto
più vicina al polo nord meno di mille
chilometri rispetto alla norvegia è una
terra che fa appunto fra i 78 e gli 82
gradi nord di latitudine coperta al 92
per cento dai ghiacciai ghiacciai che
però come tutti i ghiacciai del nostro
pianeta sono in retrazione che vuol dire
che perdono in superficie ma in artico
questo effetto è amplificato
l'amplificazione artica ancora una volta
è dovuta a leggere differenze gentili in
un sistema complesso come il clima che
provoco effetti potenzialmente
catastrofici come la scomparsa di tutti
i ghiacciai in artico catastrofici lo
possiamo già capire il cambiamento
climatico lo sentiamo su di noi tutti
giorni ma le conseguenze vere sono
eccessivamente catastrofiche un
ghiacciaio che si scioglie in artico
libera una superficie che invece che di
essere bianca come deve essere quindi
non riflette più i raggi del sole perché
è scura non riflettendo i raggi del sole
cosa succede alla superficie si riscalda
riscaldandosi di più
scioglie ancora più ghiaccio ancora
prima che si riformi e scioglie per
esempio il permafrost e quindi tutta una
serie di sistemi anche di gas anche di
acque vengono liberati e si riversano in
acque in artico dove si formano le
correnti più importanti regolatrici del
nostro clima corrente del golfo calda e
corrente del pacifico e dell'atlantico
nord che fredda l'equilibrio caldo
freddo di queste correnti è un parametro
fondamentale regolatore del nostro clima
perché lo scambio di calore fra la
superficie per l'acqua degli oceani e
l'atmosfera è quella che regola la
formazione di nubi e quando questo
equilibrio è sconvolto succedono
fenomeni tipo tornati e piogge
torrenziali anche a latitudini dove di
solito questi fenomeni non si vedono
altra conseguenza grave facilmente
immaginabile dallo scioglimento di
questi enormi ghiacciai perché il polo
nord non è una terra le svalbard
dell'ultima terra prima del polo il polo
nord e ghiaccio marino e mare che si
scioglie quindi se si scioglie e tutto
quel ghiaccio
chiaramente si innalzano tutti gli
oceani del pianeta e la prima cosa a
scomparire sono città come pescara città
costiere città delle coste ok e quindi
effetti molto grandi dovuti a
piccolissime differenze differenze tanto
piccole quanto quei due gradi di
innalzamento delle temperature medie
globali che ci siamo con 160 paesi del
mondo impegnati a contenere con misure
da prendere ancora nella conferenza sul
clima di parigi 2 gradi sembrano nulla
ma da quei due gradi anzi da un mezzo
grado dipende la possibilità per la
nostra specie è abituata a tutte queste
bellissime condizioni di equilibrio di
sopravvivere e allora prima che questo
succeda prima che si sciolgano tutti i
ghiacci dell'artico
io vi invito a vederli
a guardarli ammirarli tutti assieme a
goderceli con questo brevissimo filmato
e qui concludo la mia presentazione
[Applauso]
[Musica]
a
con
[Musica]
a
no